ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะค่ะนักเรียน
12 คนของเราสองคนของเราใช่แล้วค่ะ
เขียนวันที่ดีกว่าค่ะกูเอง
วันนี้วันอะไรคะนี่เห็นสีแดงไม่กี่ๆวัน
อาทิตย์ค่ะสายค่ะวันอาทิตย์ที่เท่าไหร่คะ
ครูเอ๋
22 ใกล้ค่ะ
เก็บปรบมือค่ะเดือนอะไรคะครูเอ๋เดือน
พฤษภาคม
เดือนที่ 5 นะคะค่ะปีพตอะไรคะ 2 คัน
หา TOA ชอบที่สุดเหรียญเหรียญปีคศอะไรคะ
2,000
22 ค่ะค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครู
วิ
แค่โมงเย็น
งอก 17:00 นพอดีเลย 17:00 นไม่ร้อนเย็น
สบาย
Oil  n สบายดีเลยค่ะถ้าไม่เย็นครับครู
หญิงร้อนมากค่ะครูเอ๋
พระอาทิตย์หายไปแล้วนะผู้หญิงอ้าวหรอร้อน
เนี่ยไปแล้วนะคะ
ได้เริ่มเบลอแล้วเอาหรอคะผู้หญิงพระ
อาทิตย์ไม่อยู่แล้วอ่ะโอเคต้องต้องอยู่
ต้องไลค์ตัวเองก่อนตายจะได้หน้าสว่างนะคะ
เออเดี๋ยวพี่ก็ 2 ไฟตัวเองหน่อยนะเดี๋ยว
มืดน่ะเสียบปลั๊กก่อนนะคะก็ได้ค่ะ
เสียบปลั๊กไฟยังมีนะคะปลั๊กเสียบเหรอค่ะ
เสียบปลั๊กก่อน
แล้วกูเอกก็เปิดมีสวิตซ์นะคะเปิดไฟ
สวิทช์ตู้
เหลืองค่ะกูเองโอเคไหมโอเคค่ะอ้าโอเคค่ะ
โอเค
ซื้อโอเค
สายเอาพัดมั้ย
ตอนแรกครูหญิงคิดว่าครูเอ๋บอกว่าไม่ร้อน
เพราะว่าครูเอ๋เนี่ยที่บ้านเนี่ยเปิดพัด
ลมหอเปิดพัดลมด้วยมีพัดลม
เหนื่อยพัดลมไม่เห็นขึ้นเห็นใครเห็นค่ะ
พัดลมเพนอ่ะสีดำนะคะใช่ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าครูเอ็มเปิดพัดลมคะแล้วก็
พัดลมเนี่ย
หมุนคู่ f เปิดพัดลมด้วยพัดลมหมุนข้างนอก
แล้วผู้เอกก็เปิดแอร์
หู
ที่ป่ะที่บ้านครูเอ๋มีพัดลมมีแอร์ให้ค่ะ
เขาขอที่บ้านผู้หญิงมีพัดลมไหมคะมีค่ะครู
เอ๋มีแอร์ไหมคะนี่ค่ะครูเอ๋ไว้ต้องทำไมทำ
หน้าแบบนี้
บ้านครูเอกก็มีพัดลมมีแอร์นะคะให้ค่ะที่
เราทำแบบนี้เนี่ยเพราะเราอยากให้นักเรียน
เนี่ยคิดว่าที่บ้านครูหญิงเราอยากให้นัก
เรียนจำใช่มั้ยแล้วนักเรียนทั้งโหลดท่าน
อะไร
ก็ให้นักเรียนคิดด้วยไงอ่ะ
หัวหน้าผู้หญิงอยากให้นักเรียนคิดอะไรคะ
เดี๋ยวน้องหญิงน้องหญิงผู้หญิงผู้หญิงถาม
จะถามใช่ไหมจะให้นักเรียนให้นักเรียนตอบ
ได้ไหมได้ๆค่ะครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงมีคำถามให้นัก
เรียนตอบได้นักเรียนคิดเชยคะ
คิดคิดนะคะแล้วก็ยกมือเราก็ตอบแล้วใส่ค่ะ
ว่าอันนี้เนี่ยบ้านครูเอ๋
แล้วก็
บ้านครูหญิงอีกหน่อยนะคะจะได้ไม่เหมือน
กัน
มี 2  Choice ก็ถือบ้านครูหญิงหรือบ้าน
ครูเอ๋ใช้ค่ะผู้หญิงครูเอกคุยวาดให้ได้ๆ
คุยอันนี้เป็นบ้านนะคะ oops หมู่
บ้านครูเอ๋ผมสั้น
ค่ะอันนี้บ้าน
ครูหญิง
บ้านผู้หญิง
นิน่าฟรีหญิงอ่ะเค้าไม่ได้จังเลย
นักเรียนจะได้เห็นชัดๆ
บ้านครูหญิง
ธนาคารเนี่ยอ่ะ
บ้านคู๋
ตายค่ะแล้วนักเรียนเนี่ยต้องคิด
ว่าบ้านครูเอ๋กลับบ้านครูหญิงเนี่ยบ้าน
ใครมีพัดลมมาก
ค่าประกันโง่พัดลมไม่ได้มีหนึ่งหรือมี
หนึ่งไม่รู้รู้บ้านใครมีพัดลมมากกว่าออก
เป็นคำถามนะในค่ะเป็นธรรมถามค่ะครูอีกคำ
ถามข้อที่ 1 ถามว่า
ลมเนี่ยเหรอค่ะนักเรียนคิดว่าครูหญิงกับ
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยบ้านใครมีพัดลมมากกว่ากันคะ
นักเรียนคิดได้ยกมือใช่ไหมคะยกมือเลย 1
คนยกมือแล้วก็ตอบถ้ายกมือเร็วได้ตอบใช่
ค่ะช้าได้ตอบไหมคะไม่ได้ตอบค่ะโอเคนะนัก
เรียนเตรียมตัวนะยอมนะคะบ้านครูเอ๋
บ้านครูหญิงบ้านใครมีพัดลมมากกว่าอ่ะแก้
ไขค่ะมากกว่าโอเคสาว
2  1 ยกมือค่ะโง่มีนักเรียนยกมือไหมคะเส
มีมีแต่ยกมือคนที่ 1 ใครอ่าคุณปวีณา
ม้าคุณประวีณายกมือมือเร็วที่สุดถ้าผู้
หญิงคะคุณประวีณาคิดว่าบ้านใครมีพัดลมมาก
กว่าคะคุณปวีณาบอกว่า
บ้านครูเอ๋มีพัดลมมากกว่าค่ะคุณปฤณัตทาย
ว่าบ้านครูเอ๋เอ๋มีพัดลมมากกว่าคุณ
ประวีณาไทยถูกหรือผิดค่ะหึอ้าวแล้วบ้าน
ครูเอ๋กลับบ้านคุยก่อนแล้วกันบ้างครูหญิง
นะคะมี
อาล้ม
1 เครื่องมีพัดลมเรื่องบางทีม 1 ตัวโอเค
ไหมใช่ค่ะมีพัดลม 1 ตัวขอโทษครับผิดบ้าน
จะพูดผิดไว้ที่นี่แล้วกันนะโอเค 1 ตัว
โอเคอ่ะไปทางนี้ดีกว่านะคะคุณเอ๋บ้านครู
หญิงดีพัดลม 1 ตัว
บ้านครูเอ๋เอ๋มีพัดลมกี่ตัว
1 เครื่อง 1 ตัวโอเคผู้หญิงไม่ได้ๆเก๋ๆ
มีพัดลมฉะนั้นแท้ง 1
มีพัดลม 2 ตัว
บ้านครูเอ๋มีพัดลมมากกว่าบ้านครูหญิงคุณ
ปวีณาตอบถูกเย้ๆ
เธอเก่งมากเก่งมากค่ะในบ้านกูเองนี้ค่ะลม
2 ตัวนะมีไม่พูด
เดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวเขาต่อไปนักเรียนรู้
บ้านครูเอ๋บอกว่ามีพัดลมอ้าวมันกดไม่ได้
เหรอคะ
ผู้หญิงได้ไหมมีอ้ามีรูปอื่นอีกไหมคะมี
ค่ะแต่ทำไมมันไม่ให้เรากดเดี๋ยวมันต้องกด
ทีละอันหรอเซ็งเลยนะคะนักเรียน
ผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงๆ
มาแล้วค่ะอ๋ออะไรคะผู้หญิง
เอ่ออ้าวผู้หญิงหายไปไหนผู้หญิง Stop
แชร์ตัวเองไปอย่างนั้นเลยค่ะนักเรียนเกย์
เดี๋ยวพี่เปิดอันนี้ดีกว่ากูเอ
แล้วผู้หญิงเปิดใหม่นะคะนักเรียนแต่ไม่
เป็นไรนักเรียนกับครูเอ๋รอแล้วๆ
กูเองกูเองดื่มน้ำได้ไหมคะดื่มน้ำ
มีน้ำนะคะแล้วก็เทน้ำรอปลื้มน้ำ
หน้านี้ค่ะครูเอ๋เห็นไหมเห็นค่ะ
โอเคอันนี้ดีกว่าผู้หญิงเลื่อนลงเอานะคะ
มองเห็นนะคะช่า
โอเค
เครื่องปรับอากาศ
ไอค่ะเครื่องกลับอันนี้นะอาหารนี้อันนี้
อันนี้คือเครื่องปรับอากาศยุ้ยครูเอ๋มัน
ยาวอะ
ไม่พูดเครื่องปรับอากาศนะคะไม่พูดค่ะ
ยายแล
เรื่องปรับออกอากาศยาว
ไม่ใจพูดพูดอะไรนะแต่
แก
ถามค่ะ
นะเรียนคิดว่าที่บ้านครูหญิงแล้วก็ที่
บ้านครูเอ๋เอ๋นะคะบ้านใครมีแอมากกว่ากัน
ไปไว้ข้างบนหน้าผู้หญิงก็ได้ค่ะอ๋อโอเค
ไม่วัดให้นะคะได้ค่ะอุ้ยเอกจะลบลบๆข้าง
บ้าน
บ้านเอ๋นะค่ะเสียงหาย
ผู้หญิงค่ะ
บ้านใครมีแอมากกว่ากันนักเรียนเดี๋ยวก็ใจ
เย็นนักเรียนใจเย็นใจเย็นดีนะคะถาม 3 นะ
คะ 2
1 ยกมือค่ะ
โอ้วใครเร็วใครเร็วใช่ไหม
คุณแร๊ดค่ะคุณแร้พิษฐาคุณ Black  tip นะ
คะ
คุณแบรดพิตต์คะคุณ Bag พิษคิดว่าบ้านครู
เอ๋หรือบ้านครูหญิงมีแอร์
มากกว่าใช่ไหมค่ะมากกว่าสระผู้หญิงคุณแรก
ตอบว่าอะไรคุณแบรดบอกครูหญิงค่ะ
บ้านผู้หญิงมีแอร์มากกว่าบ้านครูเอ๋เพราะ
ว่าบ้านครูเอ๋มีพัดลมมากกว่า
dl มากกว่าคุณแร้พิมพ์บอกคะบ้านกูเองมี
พัดลม 2 ตัวและอีกหนึ่ง
อ้ะ
บ้านครูบ้านครูเอ๋เอ๋มีแอร์กี่เครื่องคะ
หรือว่ากี่ตัว
บ้านครูเอ๋มีแอร์ 1
3  2 ค่า
โหบ้านครูเอ๋มีแอร์
3 ตัวน้ำตัว 3 เครื่องโอเคใส่น้ำครูหญิง
มีแอร์กี่ตัว
2 ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงมี 1  2  3  4  5
มายค่ะบ้านครูหญิงมีแอร์
2 เครื่องตู้
ถ้าคุณแมน
แบตผิดนะคะคุณแม่บ้านบ้านครูเอ๋มีมากกว่า
อ่ะค่ะบ้านกูเอ๋มีแอลมากกว่าบ้านครูหญิง
คู๋มีแอร์ 2 ห้องแอร์ 3 พัดลม 2 ไม่ร้อน
แน่ๆค่ะครูเอ๋หนาวค่ะตอนนี้อ่ะต่อไปค่ะ
เครื่องของต่อไปรูปต่อไปนี้
อะไรคะครูเอ๋ดูก็
มีเท่าไหร่
อารีบค่ะเตารีดนะฮะๆนะเรียนนักเรียนเนี่ย
คิดว่าบ้านครูเอ๋เอ๋หรือว่าบ้านครูหญิง
บ้านใครมีเตารีดมากกว่ากันอ๋อโอเคนะคะนัก
เรียนเตรียมตัว 3
R1 ยกมือค่ะคุณลิซ่าคุณลิซ่าเร็วที่สุด
Lisa ยกมือเร็วที่สุดคุณไม่ชัดตอบอะไรคะ
คุณลิซ่าตอบครูเอ๋ค่ะ
ไม่ทราบหรอกว่าข้อที่ 1 ข้อที่สองครูเอ๋
มีมากกว่าคุณคิดกูวีซ่าก็เลยคิดครูเอ๋น่า
จะมีมากกว่าครูหญิง
ขอบคุณค่ะคุณได้ซ่าเออ
ผู้หญิงคะ
บ้านครูหญิงมีเตารีดกี่ตัวคะนั่นครูหญิง
มีเตารีด
กี่ตัวกี่เต่าโอเคเนาะได้ค่ะอังกฤษศาสตร์
1 ตัวสระครูเอ๋ขอบ้านครูหญิงมีเตารีด 1
ตัว 1  9
บ้านครูเอ๋จะมีเตารีดกี่ตัวคะ
โอ๋
หนู
2 ตัว
บ้าง ZA มีมั้งกว่าผู้หญิงอีกแล้วอยากดู
มั้ยเดี๋ยวนักเรียนคิดคูเอกโกหกไม่ได้ค่ะ
ดูได้ครูเอ๋เนี่ยกำลังเดินไปแล้วก็กำลัง
จะไปหาเตารีดนะเตารีดที่บ้านครูเอ๋มานัก
เรียนเห็นครูเอ๋อยู่ข้างหลังใช่ไหมคะเป็น
แบล็คกราวน์เบลอๆอยู่ข้างหลังผู้หญิงไม่
อยู่แล้วอ้าว
[เพลง]
ลืมขอโทษ
อ้าว
ครูเอ๋
จริงๆกูเอ๋นะมี 3 ตัว
ไม่มี 3 กลัวว่ากูเออลืมพี่เก๋ให้ให้เขา
ไป 2 ตัวขอ
เลื่อน 1 ตัว R ไม่ได้มากกว่าแล้วขอโทษขอ
โทษไม่เป็นไรค่ะมีเท่ากันเอากันเอากันเรา
จะไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรนักเรียนบอกโอเคมั้ย
ผิดถูกโอเคว่าจริงๆกู a ซื้อ 3 ตัวแล้วกู
เอง
ไม่เอาให้ให้นะคะเหลือ 1 ค่ะ
เอาไป
ต่อไปนะคะครูเองอะไรโอ้โหโหเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋
หม้อหุงข้าวเนี่ยครูหญิงมี 2 รูปมีรูปนี้
แบบนี้นะคะแล้วก็แบบนี้ที่บ้านครูเอ๋มี
แบบไหนอ่ะหรือว่ามี 2 แบบก็รู้หมดสิฮะ
โอเคเหมือนกันหม้อหุงข้าวอันนี้ก็หม้อหุง
ข้าวนะคะนักเรียนหม้อหุงข้าวหม้อหุงข้าว
อ่ะเอารถเรียนหม้อหุงชัยค่ะนักเรียนรนัก
เรียนคิดว่า
บ้านใครมีหม้อหุงข้าวมากกว่ากันเดี๋ยวผู้
หญิงนักเรียนบอกหม้อหุงข้าวก็ต้องมี 1
เอ้า
บางบ้านอาจจะมีมากกว่าหนึ่งก็ได้นะคะนัก
เรียน
โอเค
เออ
นักเรียนพร้อมนะคะป่าวตัวเอง not ได้เลย
ค่ะแต้ม 2  1 ยกมือ
คุณเค้าเร็วที่สุดอ่ะคุณเค้าคิดว่าบ้าน
ใครมีหม้อหุงข้าวมากกว่าคะคุณเคราร์ดต่อ
ไปว่ากินข้าวเนี่ยเรียนกับเรามานานแล้วนะ
คะคุณเขาถ่ายวะบ้านครูเอ๋ค่ะอ๋อ
บ้านผู้หญิงมีหม้อหุงข้าวกี่ใบมองแฟนครู
หญิงมีหม้อหุงข้าว
000 ใบ
มี
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าบ้านกูเองมีหม้อหุงข้าวกี่
ใบผู้หญิงคิดเสียงไหมวิ่งได้ให้กูเอง 1
ควรเอมมี่ 1 เปลี่ยนจังเลย 3 ใบ
ถูก
ผู้หญิงทำไมดีใจ
มี 3 ใบ
บ้านครูเอ๋มีมากกว่าค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ไม่ได้ซื้อนะคะใช่ผู้ a อยู่คอนโด
คอนโดที่คอนโดมีหม้อหุงข้าว 1 ใบ
ครูเอ๋มาครูเอ๋มีหม้อหุงข้าวของครูเอ๋ 1
ใบ
คู๋เข้าที่คอนโดเนี่ยคอนโดมีแล้ว 1 ใบคุณ
เอ๋เอามา 1 ใบครูหญิงให้ครูเอ๋อีก 1 ใบ
ครูเอ๋มีหม้อหุงข้าว 3 ใบ
ครูเอ๋ถามว่าใครจะมีหม้อหุงข้าวมากกว่า 1
ใบครูเอ๋ไงคะ
โอ๊ยมีเยอะมากๆตายค่ะต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋กลับ
ไปเครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้าต่อไปคืออะไร
ทีวี
ทีวีทีวีหรือว่า
โทรทัศน์
ไม่ใช่เขา
โทรทัศน์นะดูหนังโทรทัศน์หรือว่าชีวีที่
นักเรียนคิดว่า
บ้านใครมีมากกว่าจันทร์
[เพลง]
พร้อมนะคะนักเรียน
3  2  1 ยกมือโอ้คุณจะผมจะหิวออกผม
อยากตอบมากๆต้องรีบยกมือ
คุณแตฮีตอบว่าบ้านใครมีโทรทัศน์มากกว่าคะ
คุณ Jae  Hee ตอบว่า
บ้านครูหญิง
พูดได้ที่บอกบ้านครูหญิงอ่ะครูเอ๋
โอเคบ้านครูหญิงมีโทรทัศน์กี่เครื่องคะๆ
ครูหญิงมีโทรทัศน์
1 เครื่องค่ะนี่นะ
หมู่บ้านครูเอ๋มีโทรทัศน์กี่เครื่องคะ
บ้านครูเอ๋ปีนี้ใช่ไหมคะปีนี้อ้าวมีหลาย
ปีด้วย
2,000  22 เนี่ยมีโทรทัศน์ 1 เครื่องค่ะ
ชาอ้าวงั้นก็ไม่มีใครมีมากกว่ากันเท่ากัน
น้องเรามีโทรทัศน์เท่ากันนะคะ 2,000  20
11 ครูเอ๋มี 2 เครื่องงั้นปีที่แล้วครู
เอ๋มีมากกว่าครูหญิงชายปีนี้เหลือ 1
เครื่องค่ะโอเคต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋เครื่อง
ใช้ไฟฟ้านะคะ
แล้วพี่ไม่มีคอมพิวเตอร์เลยอ่ะหมายถึงว่า
ไม่ใช่ไม่มีในรูปเนี่ยไม่มีสิ่งไม่แน่ใจ
ว่าเป็นเครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้าไหมใช้ตอบอ่ะครู
อ่ะพี่เก๋
เรื่องปิ้งขนมปังค่ะ
เรียนคิดว่า
บ้านใครมีมากกว่ากัน
3  2  1 ยกมือค่ะ
คุณซาร่านักเรียนใหม่ของเราคุณสาระคุณ
ซาร่าตอบว่าครูหญิงหรือครูเอ๋มีเครื่อง
ปิ้งขนมปังมากกว่าคะคุณซาร่าตอบว่าครูเอ๋
ค่ะครูเอ๋คุณสารารถชาร่ารู้จักเรานิด
หน่อยนักเรียนใหม่ใช่ผู้หญิงคะครูหญิงมี
เครื่องปิ้งขนมปังกี่เครื่องคะครูหญิงมี
เครื่องปิ้งขนมปัง 0
ถ้าไม่มีค่ะ
ครูเอ๋มีเครื่องปิ้งขนมปังกี่เครื่องโหมี
เยอะหรอ
ครูเอ๋
ไม่มีเครื่องปิ้งขนมปัง
เรียน
ต่อยผู้หญิงน่ะขอโทษคุณซาร่าเราสองคนไม่
มีเครื่องปิ้งขนมปังคิดว่านักเรียนมีมาก
กว่าเราเราไม่กินไง
เรามีศูนย์ตัวค่ะไทยค่ะขอโทษนะคะนักเรียน
ไม่เป็นไรต่อไปดีกว่าต่อไปดีกว่าต่อไปต่อ
ไป
คิดว่าเราน่าจะมี
ไมโครเวฟ
อันนี้ไมโครเวฟผู้หญิงวันนี้ขอเปลี่ยน
บ้านเป็นสีแดงแล้วกันอ่ะได้ค่ะ f
หญิงอันนี้น่าจะเป็นไมโครเวฟใช่ไหมค่ะ
ไมโครเวฟนะคะ
โรเวปนักเรียนคิดว่าบ้านใครมีมากกว่า
จันทร์
3  2  1 ยกมือค่ะโอ้คุณลิซ่ายกมือได้อีก
แล้วหน้าเก่งมากสร้างเซลล์มากบริษัทตอบ
บ้านใครมีไมโครเวฟมากกว่าคะคุณลิซ่าบอก
ว่า
บ้านครูหญิงค่ะ
ว่าผู้หญิงไม่ชอบทำอาหารก็เลยมีไมโครเวฟ
ฮ่าๆๆ
ผู้หญิงคะบ้านผู้หญิงมีไมโครเวฟกี่ตัวคะ
บ้านครูหญิงมีไมโครเวฟ
มี 1 คือเรื่องค่าแล้วบ้านครูเอ๋มีกี่
เครื่องกับอ้าๆกลัวเราหรอมีมากกว่าเรา
หรือเปล่านะ
มีเท่าไหร่คะบ้านครูเอ๋
มี
ไมโครเวฟๆแทงๆ
เมอริส
I  O
เพลงผู้หญิงดีใจนะไม่ใช่คุณลิซ่าดีใจกู้
หญิงมีมากกว่ารู้ S มีมึงเองไม่เป็นไร
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงย้ายออกจากกรุงเทพฯเอาให้
ครูเองไงใช่ของครูหญิงค่ะ
ของคอนโดทุก
เวเสียใจเลยอ่ะไม่ใช่ของผู้หญิง
ไมโครเวฟไงใช่ค่ะชิ้นต่อไปค่ะมีคู่หู
อะไรตู้เย็นตู้เย็น
นักเรียนคิดว่าบ้านใครมีตู้เย็นมากกว่า
กัน
ไม่ได้บอกใครจะมีตู้เย็นหลายเครื่องที่
กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหม
โอ้ยงั้นเอาบ้านพี่ชลบุรีด้วยก็ได้
นักเรียนมีบ้านครูเอ๋เอ๋ที่ชลบุรีบ้านครู
หญิงที่ชลบุรีนะคะไม่เอา
บ้านของครูหญิงที่กรุงเทพฯที่ชลบุรีที่
อื่นด้วย
บ้านของเราลุยอันนั้นเยอะเท่าไหร่เอ้าก็
กูเองมีบ้านที่สุดประการไงไม่เอาไว้เอา
โอเคบ้านที่กรุงเทพฯกลับบ้านที่ชลบุรี
หือนักเรียนคิดว่าถ้าบ้านใครมีตู้เย็นมาก
กว่ากันน้องสาว 2  1 ยกมือค่ะคน Robert
คุณโรเบิร์ตแพททินสันนะคะเร็วมากคุณ
ระเบิดงงทำไมมีบ้านกรุงเทพบ้านชลบุรี
คุณโรเบิร์ตคิดบ้านครูหญิงหรือบ้านครูเอ๋
มีตู้เย็นมากกว่าคะคุณโรเบิร์ตทายว่าบ้าน
ครูเอ๋ค่ะบ่เคยบอกครูเอ๋ชอบทำอาหารน่าจะ
มีตู้เย็นตู้เย็นตู้เย็นมากๆ
นักเรียนคะเฉลยนะคะ
ที่กรุงเทพฯมีตู้เย็นหนึ่งอ้าวแล้วที่
ชลบุรีหรอคะบ้านที่ชลบุรีมีตู้เย็น 2 ค่ะ
ครูเอ๋มีตู้เย็น 3 เครื่อง
เรือง
บ้านที่กรุงเทพครูพี่ตุ้ย
n11 บ้านที่ชลบุรีมีตู้เย็นกี่เครื่อง
นิ 2 ใช่ไหมสองหรือสัตว์คือหรือว่ามี 3
ก็มี 3 น้องชายฉันมีอีกลืม
บ้านครูหญิงอ่ะคุณแม่ผู้หญิงมีตู้เย็นตู้
เย็นตู้เย็น 3 เครื่องเป็นไว้ครูหญิงมี
คู่ 3 ตู้ใช่ไหมค่ะมี 3 ตู้นะคะบ้านครู
ยอดผิดค่ะบ้านครูหญิงมีตู้เย็นมากกว่า
บ้านครูเองคุณโรเบิร์ตผิดค่ะ
ก็ว่านกูเอ๋มีคู๋กับคุณแม่ตู้เห็น 2 โอเค
แล้วบ้านผู้หญิงมีน้องด้วยนะคะคุณโร
เบิร์ตอ่ะต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋อะไรนะอะไรนะอ๋อ
แต่เรื่อง
เครื่องซักผ้า
น้องชาวบ้านที่กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมคะได้ค่ะอา
นักเรียนคิดว่าว่าบ้านใครมีมากกว่ากันคิด
ว่าบ้านใครอ่ะ 3  2  1 ยกมือค่ะ
คุณ John คุณ John สวีเดนนะคะคุณ John
สวีเดนคุณ John ตอบว่าบ้านใครมีเครื่อง
ซักผ้ามากกว่าค่ะคุณ John เนี่ยคิดนะคิดๆ
แล้วก็บอกว่า
บ้านครูเอ๋
คุณจอยบอกพี่เอกชอบซักผ้าแล้วก็
อ้าวงั้นพี่จอยก็คิดครูหญิงไม่ชอบซักผ้า
เหรอจ๊ะ
ครูหญิงชอบซักผ้าไงกูเอกขี้เกียจก็เลยงง
ค่ามากๆค่ะ
หรือผู้หญิงคะ
คู๋เฉลยตัวเองนะคะพี่เอ๋
บ้านครูเอ๋มีเครื่องซักผ้า 1 เครื่องค่ะ
อะบ้านครู ami  1
บ้านครูอ่านเรื่องซักผ้ากี่เครื่องคะ
เดี๋ยวพี่ขอดูก่อนนะครับครูเอ๋มีเยอะเหรอ
คะอ๋อ
นี่ค่ะ
ไงมีคุณจองจรสวีเดนก็ตอบทุกนะคะครูเอ๋เอ๋
มีมากกว่า
มายค่ะอันนี่อีกไหมคะมีค่ะมีกี่มีน่าจะ
ได้อีกนะคะ
V อันนี้เรียกอะไรอ่ะไม่ใช่ไมโครเวฟใช่
ไหมกูเอ๋ไม่ใช่ไมโครเวฟเรียกว่า
จะเอาอบอ่ะเตาอบใช่ไหมในรูปเนี่ยเขาอบ
พิซซ่านะคะ
นักเรียนคิดว่าว่าบ้านใครมีเตาอบมากกว่า
จันทร์เนื้อตัวเองนะปะใครดีต้องหนึ่งค่ะ
ยกมือคุณทาดาชิ
คุณธาดาขาเก่งมากค่ะคุณทาดาชิตอบครูเอ๋
เลยค่ะไม่ต้องถามไม่ตอบผู้หญิงเหรอใบอ่ะ
คุณทาชิบอกผู้หญิงมีไมโครเวฟแล้ว
บ้านครูเอ๋มีเตาอบ 1
1 อะไร
191 เตาก็ได้ 1 เครื่องก็เล่าเตา 1 เตา
หรือ 1 เครื่องค่ะ 1 เครืองบ้านครูหญิงนะ
คะมีเป่าอบอีกเรื่องค่ะบ้านครูตัวลิงมี
เตาอบ
เฮ้ยศ.
0 อ้าวผู้หญิงเขียนวันสองสิ่งแกล้งกลัว
เอ๋ทิ้ง
[ปรบมือ]
ไม่มีค่ะไม่มีควีนอยากได้เตาอกมากๆในทั้ง
หมดเนี่ยซื้อค่ะเล็กๆเรา
ก็กำลังคิดนะคะอยากได้เตาอบนะคะมากกว่า
Love เตาอบนะมีตั้งแต่ 2,000 บาทประมาณ
2,500
บาทค่ะถึงโอเค
แพงๆใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋แตงๆถ้าเล็กๆก็ 2,000
กว่าบาทใหญ่ๆใหญ่ๆก็แพงอือมันเป็นเหนื่อย
ถ้า
คิดว่าไม่ต้องใหญ่มากเนาะ
เขาว่าบ้านไม่หมูผู้หญิงไม่ได้ทำใหญ่ๆ
อยู่แล้วค่ะคุณเองซัก 5,000 ก็โอเคแล้ว
ครูหญิง
ได้ค่ะ 5,000 อย่าผู้หญิงผู้หญิงมาอยู่
กรุงเทพก็ให้พูห์ a บ้านกูเอกก็จะมีไว้
เนี่ยก็คือยักษ์ผู้หญิงไม่อยู่กรุงเทพฯ
ให้รู้เหนะคะเรียน
เอไอคิวดี
อีก 1 อันนะกันอีกหนึ่งอย่างแล้วกันนะคะ
ครูเอ๋ได้ค่ะได้ค่ะได้นะอะไรเนี่ย
เครื่องปั่น
โอเคค่ะคุณลบตรงนี้ก่อนก็ได้ค่ะคุยกันจะ
ลดนึงนะคะนักเรียนคิดว่าบ้านครูเอ๋เอ๋
กลับบ้านครูหญิงมั้ยคะบ้านใครมีเครื่อง
ปั่นมากกว่ากันเอาบ้านที่ขออย่างเดียวใช่
ไหมครับเทพกรุงเทพฯ 3  2  1 ยกมือค่ะ
คุณ John คุณ John อเมริกา
จรตอบว่าบ้านใครมีเครื่องปั่นมากกว่าคะกู
จองถึงทานคิดนะคะแล้วก็คิดอยากสอบครูหญิง
นะแต่ตอบครูเอ๋ค่ะ
ขอบคุณค่ะผู้หญิงบ้านหนานบ้านครูเอ๋นะ
บ้านกูเอ๋มีไอ้ตอบก่อน 1 เครื่องค่ะอ๋อ
บ้านครูเอมี 1 เครื่องบ้านครูหญิงมีกี่
เครื่องคะ
นะคะ
โค่เย้
ก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ผู้หญิงไปเอามาจากไหน 5 เครื่อง
เขียนเหมือน 5
ร้านปิ่งคะแนนครูเอ๋ค่ะไม่มีบ้านผู้หญิง
ไม่มีแต่บ้านคุยมากกว่านะคะใส่ค่ะ
เครื่องดูดฝุ่นได้ๆพอดีเลยป่ะรู้ได้ไงเขา
ก็ต่อไปขึ้นเครื่องดูดโฟน
อ้านักเรียนนักเรียนคิดว่าบ้านครูหญิงมี
นะบ้านครูหญิงมีบอกเลยมีก็มีอ้ะนักเรียน
คิดว่าบ้านใครมีมากกว่ากัน
ให้ฟังเสียงกับนั้น 3  2  1 ยกมือค่ะคุณ
แคทคุณแคทยกมือค่ะคุณแคทตอบว่าบันแพทตอบ
ว่า
บ้านครูเก๋
กูอันต่อมาก็เลยหนีมากกว่า
มีตอบต่อแล้วกันนะคะคุณครูหญิงนี้บ้านมี
1 เครื่องค่ะครูเอกเรื่องดูดฝุ่นบ้านครู
เอ๋ไม่ไปนิดนึง 2-3 โต๊ะมา
บ้านคุยกับพี่ 2 เครื่อง
โอ้วบ้านครูเอ๋ทำไมมีตั้ง 2 เครื่องค่ะ
เครื่องดูดฝุ่นเนี่ยมีเครื่องที่เป็นแบบ
Robot นะคะอ๋ออ๋อกลมกลมแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะ
เป็นโรบอลแล้วก็มีเครื่องที่ถืออีก 1
เครื่องนะคะครูหญิงให้ครูย-กจ่ายค่ะเพราะ
ว่าพี่เอ๋
พี่เอ๋ไม่ชอบผู้หญิงให้ Robot คู๋เลยอ่ะ
ผู้หญิงก็เลยหา Robot เป็นหมื่นเลยนะคะ
หมื่นเลยเหรอประมาณ
นั้นดีมากนะ Robot มี The  Memory จำได้
แบบเอามันไม่สะอาดอ่ะถ้ากูเอกก็ใช้ 2
ครั้งไง Robot ครั้งที่ 1 ก็คืออันนี้นะ
คะก็น้องทั้งหมดนะคะที่นักเรียนรู้ก็คือ
เครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้าเราเรียกว่าเครื่องใช้ไฟ
ฟ้าวันนี้เวลาหมดแล้วใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะแล้ว
เดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้านะคะวัน
นี้ก็สวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบาย